we spent a long time looking for our
Jack and Jacob Tremblay stood out from
early taped readings that I got sent yes
lovely that he's like that one yeah I
would do exactly that Jake Jake is very
unique I think really quite amazing I'm
on implant
come on antiques Nick my care there's a
little boy that was born in room
he lived in room until he was five and
one day his mom wanted to put him out of
the room but she didn't want to but when
he's out of the room
she's very shining for me scared of
everything like this when I was act like
that we've been extremely lucky with
Jacob he's eight years old playing five
but he's also an experienced actor he's
done this before so he's not coming to
us for the first time these parents stab
me no much why not I do a set he's
incredibly bright and great
concentration but he's still a kid he's
still a boy still full of life and fun
and mischief his mom said do you have
any questions for Bri and he was like
yeah I have to actually what's your
favorite color what's your favorite
animal and oh and do you like Star Wars
there was three questions and that was
the beginning of it
like it won't it free helps me Ken so
fought someone when I need be serious he
helps me be serious
all people are nice people because they
help me be serious